chaque ce qu'on est content et nous
sommes vraiment pied d'oeuvre d'heure en
heure en fait la bonne nouvelle c'est
que hervé pour la région a été actée et
là on va le réaliser sous forme
temporaire
on appelle ça d'ailleurs le ton pour
hervé et là il nous reste quelques jours
quelques semaines jusqu'au 11 mai où on
a encore la possibilité de mettre en
place de façon relativement facile parce
que le trafic motorisé a chuté de 90%
nous devons absolument mettre en place
une carte qui va très rapidement indiqué
à tous les habitants où ils peuvent se
déplacer en sécurité à vélo
si on a choisi avec avec nos
spécialistes et les régions des
itinéraires qui vont le long des axes de
transports publics les plus attirés et
là je penserai horaire à b et d et aussi
la ligne 13 du métro et c'est donc là
surtout en priorité que nous allons
mettre en place des itinéraires
cyclables des pistes cyclables
temporaire pour permettre aux habitants
de découvrir leur chemin à vélo et de le
faire avec une distanciation sociales
appropriées